- In life, it's a very simple principle,
but all success comes
from completing tasks.
Fully functioning people, these
are the top 10% of people,
never complain and never explain.
If you're stuck in a dead
end job that you can't leave,
because you have no money set aside,
you have put a brake on your potential.
- Hello, Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the
major problems of the world.
So, to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from motivational speaker,
author and sales expert Brian Tracy
and my take on his Top 10
Rules for Success, Volume Two.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- Act as if you already
had a goal that you desire.
So, let us say, for example, that you
want to be financially independent.
You want to be financially successful.
How would you behave if you
were financially successful?
How would you dress, how
would you organize your life?
How would you treat other people?
Sometimes I say, imagine that you
are financially independent.
You're independently wealthy,
and you're only doing your
current job as a curtesy
to your boss and to keep
yourself busy during the day,
but basically you're an
extremely wealthy person.
You've inherited an enormous
amount of money from some source.
How would you behave if you were already
the wealthy person that you desire to be?
Many people don't realize that,
if you behave like a poor person,
there's an old saying that
poor people, poor folks have poor ways.
If you behave like a poor
person, you'll always be poor.
If you dress like a bum,
if you have a messy home
or apartment, if your car is dirty
with junk in the back seat,
that's how poor people live.
And, what happens is that
you're surrounding yourself
with the image of being poor,
and you cannot change your outer world
until you change your inner world.
Ask yourself what are the three
most important things
that I do in my work?
And, then you have to discipline yourself
to start with the most important task
and work on that task
until it is completed.
And, it's a very simple principle,
but it is the beginning and the middle
and the end of success.
Decide on your most important task,
begin immediately and work on that task
with self discipline
until it is 100% complete.
In life, it's a very simple principle,
but all success comes
from completing tasks.
It's not from working at tasks,
it's from completing tasks.
It is only when you complete
tasks that you are successful.
The most important key
to success is to start
and complete one important task
first thing in the morning.
If you--
- [Man] Eat the frog.
- Eat the frog.
If you try to do many things,
you end up doing nothing.
So, you make a list of all
your work before you begin,
and then you ask, "If I
could only do on thing
"on this list, which one
activity is the most important?"
And then you do that activity,
only that until it's complete.
If you start every day
by completing a task,
you will double and
triple your productivity.
You will find that every
major change in your life
is accompanied by a person or persons
who either opens or closes doors for you.
The possibility of your
achieving the best life for you
will be determined by the number of people
who know you and like you and
who are willing to help you.
Now, in order to broaden
your network of contacts,
you must network continually
at every opportunity.
There seems to be a direct relationship
between the number of people you know
and how successful you are.
Now, to network successfully,
the simple strategy is this.
When you meet a new person,
ask them what they do.
Ask for their business card
and then see if you can't find
something that you can do for them.
And, the one thing that
people like the most
is if you can send them a customer.
Many people who network are thinking
"What can I get from this other person?"
Your strategy when you meet a new person
who can be helpful to you is to think
"What can I give to this person?
"What can do for this person
and how quickly can I do it?"
That way, you sow seeds of people who'll
be prepared to help you in the future.
A fear of rejection is
caused by a hyper concern
for the opinions of other people.
In William Glasser's
work on what they call
the fully functioning person,
they had a wonderful line.
They said fully functioning people,
these are the top 10% of people,
never complain and never explain.
They never defend themselves,
is they do it or they don't do it,
but they never feel that they have to
explain themselves to anyone else.
If someone doesn't like it,
they say, "And your point is?"
And they just don't care.
And, your job is to reach the point
where you say "I like myself.
"I like myself.
"I'm responsible for own life,
"and if someone doesn't
like what I do or don't do,
"that's their problem,
it's not my problem."
And if you repeat this to
yourself over and over again,
you can actually reprogram yourself
and cancel out and override
all the previous programming
that's generating these fears that
you experience in your adult life.
Here's a very important story.
They studied the 500 owners of
the fastest growing
businesses in the world,
and they asked them, "Why did
you choose this business?"
And all of them said,
"I choose this business
"because I really love the product.
"I wanted the product for myself,
"and, so, I developed it for myself."
Like the founder of eBay was lookin'
for a way to sell his candy dispensers.
He had a collection.
And there wasn't anything, so he created
a little auction site on the
internet at the beginning,
and then, he found he could
sell other things in an auction,
and built eBay, one of the most
successful companies in the world.
But, he started it because
he wanted it for himself.
So, you'll always be successful
if you create the product or service
'cause it's something that you want
and believe in for yourself.
Financial freedom means that
you're making enough money
so that you don't have to
think about it continually,
or, best of all, that you
never think about it at all.
Most people worry about
money all the time,
and that's a lousy way to live.
Nearly 80% of the population is
preoccupied with money problems.
They think about it when they wake up
and they think about it during the day
and they think about it when
they go to sleep at night
and sometimes, it keeps
'em awake at night.
The only way for you to
achieve financial freedom
is for you to define your
financial goals clearly
and then make plans to
achieve those goals.
There is a process that
you've heard about,
it's called serendipity.
And, serendipity is defined as the process
of making happy discoveries,
is that you find things
that seem to conspire together
to bring you the things you want in life.
You meet the right person,
you read the right article,
you get the right email
or phone call and so on.
It's called serendipity,
happy discoveries.
Now, what they've found, and, by the way,
this is a common factor
that you can tap into,
what they found is that
people who are, seem to have
serendipitous, wonderfully
coincidental experiences,
are people that are
characterized by one thing.
They're looking.
Nobody has a serendipitous experience
sitting there watchin'
television at night,
or reading the paper
or drinking in the bar.
In other words, these
people who have these happy,
just make these happy discoveries
are people who are looking.
And so, one of the most important
requirements for success,
again, based on years
and years of research
which I've done, is ambition.
Ambition means that you're
hungry, is that you're hungry,
you want to be successful.
You want to be successful more
that almost anything else.
Always choose higher quality
rather than lower cost.
Most companies think the way to sell more
is to lower the price.
But, the true reason for success,
and there's years of research,
is to improve the quality of your product.
You improve the quality of your product.
There was a study of the 500
fastest growing companies
in the world that came out last year.
And, they found the number
one place where they invested
was improving the quality of the product.
That, if you had a certain amount of money
to invest in your business,
it was not on advertising
or machinery or computers.
- Quality.
- Improve the quality.
That's the key to success.
- So.
- Having money in the bank
gives you greater freedom
and the ability to take advantage
of opportunities when they come along.
If you're broke or in debt,
and an opportunity comes along,
you have no options open to you.
There's nothing that you can do.
So, having money makes you free.
One of the most important
things I ever learned in life
is that you're only as
free as your options.
If you have no options, if you have to do
whatever it is you're
doing, you have no choice,
you have no freedom.
If you're stuck in a dead
end job that you can't leave
because you have no money set aside,
you have put a brake on your potential.
You are locked in place and you have
no option for moving forward.
You can end up spinning your wheels
and losing months and years of your time
by the very fact that you have no choice
but to accept whatever
is being handed to you.
But, if you have money, they
call this opportunity money,
if you have money put aside,
you can walk away from a bad job
and you can take time to find
exactly the right job for you.
This idea of saving up
money so that you are
available to take opportunities
has transformed many people's lives.
Let me leave you with the
last verse of Carry On.
There are some who drift
out in the deserts of doubt,
and some who in negativity wallow.
There are others I know who in piety go
because of a heaven to follow.
But, to labor with zest
and to give of your best
for the sweetness and joy of the giving,
to help folks along
with a hand and a song,
why there's the real sunshine of living.
Carry on, carry on, fight
the good fight and true.
There's big work to do.
Believe in your mission,
greet life with a cheer,
there's big work to do,
and that's why you're here.
Carry on, carry on, that the
world be the better for you
so, at last when you die,
let this be your cry,
carry on, my soul, carry on.
(clapping)
Ladies and gentlemen,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you will resolve with whatever
life hands you to carry on
there is nothing that can stop you
from achieving the greatness
for which you were created.
Thank you.
- Hear!
- God bless.
(clapping)
Hello, this is Brian Tracy.
I wanted to thank Evan
for making this video
and sharing these important
messages with his audience.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
If you want to get your pick of who
I should profile next in the Top 10s,
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Clyde Hayz.
Clyde, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book Your One Word,
and taking that picture
of you and the book.
I love it, thank you for
posting it and sending it in.
I appreciate the support, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see ya soon.
- Self awareness is a critical
part of mental health.
This is how you discover
why you react and respond
the way you do to people
and situations around you.
Successful people understand themselves
and why they think and
feel the way they do,
and that's one of the
things that you learn.
When you can understand
and accept yourself,
you can begin moving forward
in other areas of your life.
Your level of ability in your field
will determine the quality
and quantity of your results.
The better you get at what you do,
the easier is it for you to start
moving forward and to get a
particular level of results.
As you increase your
skill level in your field
through study and experience,
you get better and better
at doing the small things
that increase the speed and
predictability of your results.
Remember, skills are things
that can be developed
over and over and all
business skills are learnable.
You can learn any skill you need to learn
to achieve any business goal
that you can set for yourself.
Talk to yourself
positively about the person
that you want to be and the
things that you want to have.
When you see a beautiful car, you say,
"I drive a car like that pretty soon."
When you see beautiful clothes, you say,
"Those are the kind of clothes I wear."
When you see beautiful homes, you say,
"I'm going to live in a house like that."
Just keep talking to yourself about
the things that you want to have
and the person that you want to be,
and each time you do,
you're reprogramming.
And your subconscious mind is
accepting your new commands
and is working 24 hours a day
to bring them into your life.
Just give it a try and see what happens.